couteau à la main il a maintenant tous
les est du cuisinier pourtant aziz
possède un bac + 5 dans le domaine de
l'eau réfugié politique
il a fui le soudan il travaille ici
depuis deux ans n'est besoin d'argent
pour faire relire ma famille en france
et aussi pour après de poids pour études
dans le domaine en france et pour ça il
se cuisine et et après j'aimerais bien
couvert ici la patronne c'est myriam
elle avait des difficultés à recruter et
un jour elle a entendu dire que le
centre de pouilly cherchait des
employeurs pour des demandeurs de la
ville alors elle a tenté l'expérience
c'est vrai que j'avais un petit peu peur
au départ parce que je m'étais dit
prendre un réfugié avec les polémiques
qui a aujourd'hui sur eux c'était dur
mais finalement j'ai dit allez hop on y
va c'est parti ça fait deux ans qu'il
est avec nous ça se passe très bien
il s'est bien adapté à son travail c'est
s'adapte bien aux gens arnay-le-duc dans
le secteur de beaune un bassin d'emploi
ou en 2017 sur les 1000 96 postes
proposés dans l'hôtellerie-restauration
seul 993 ont trouvé preneur au caté du
nord en cuisine de réfugiés soudanais et
un erythréen ayman joumaa y kamal
semblent eux aussi avoir trouvé leurs
marques
je trouve qu'il est personne gentille et
pas trop les clientes frénétique pour ça
je suis très content une brigade qui a
redonné du souffle à ce restaurant
rurales selon sonia la gérante de
l'établissement pour elle
recruter un réfugié ce n'est pas juste
combler un emploi vacant
moi ce que je veux c'est que on
reconnaisse leurs véritables qualités
professionnelles de cuisine
et que nous professionnels français on
sache les accompagner met des diplômes
en face de leur expérience leur trouver
des postes de qualité dans les
différents restaurants de côte d'or et
de bourgogne et il faut que les états
nous accompagnent là dessus le syndicat
de l'hôtellerie restauration doit
rencontrer le gouvernement à l'automne
il espère étendre les possibilités
d'embauché ou migrants non réfugiés